[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i've donated my sperm and i i was chosen
not i don't want to be notified but like
somebody's
you know
seriously bro yeah and the doctor what
are you doing bro they the doctors told
me in there they said look they said you
know because i got a doctorate degree
they're like you got a doctorate degree
they're like so your sperm will be women
are going to take the sperm because the
level of education see if children out
there probably probably but i i told
them like i don't want to be notified
i just want to give that glue dead beat
down give that glue out bro no but but
my point is is like what you just said
it's like when you donate your sperm
like women are out there that are like
you know maybe they're a lesbian couple
or maybe they just don't want a man in
their life but they want to procreate so
that's kind of what they do they they're
they she looked at my profile if someone
did pick they had a picture too they
have everything whatever headshot did
you give them um i thought what was it
what was it no i took a picture in the
office dude i would only donate a little
bit of sperm to him how much did you
give him i gave him one load man
i'll give him one [ __ ] level
i shot it out what a cheap date dude
dude what did they give you
um what'd i get maybe 125 150
cash money play cash money cuz
bro what a [ __ ] because i'm not [ __ ]
120 i went out to applebee's in times
square i've never been in a voluntary
gay sex act but when i was a kid i was
like the runt of my friend group i was
like 10 and my friends were 13 14. i
could see that and the mckenzie brothers
one time i was taking his [ __ ] were they
red-headed uh no but they were twins and
they had shaved heads they were crazy
irish kids from queens one of them sat
on my legs when i was taking a [ __ ] and
the other one jumped on my mom's sink
and skull [ __ ] me two pumps and my
head hit off the back
of the backs i swear to go the back
ceramic tile and knocked down one of my
mom's ceramic tiles and and i told it i
was horsing around playing ball but
really i got skull [ __ ] by by one of
these dudes and i remember tasting a
little bit of his pre-comment oh yeah it
was weird man i took one right off the
uvula and i did it and i and i didn't uh
that's a hot i didn't like it no the
problem is i didn't like it i did not
like it but i also didn't hate it so
that's why i'll say
i can confidently tell you that i'm i'm
a hundred i'm a hundred percent sure i
am not gay mm-hmm but i'm also 100 sure
i'm not straight so you tell me what
that means
well i think there's a l there's a thing
called element of surprise gay where
somebody surprises you with a gay act
like a pearl harbor gay yeah like pearl
harbor but yeah suddenly you're just
resting and then a bunch of wieners
falling you out uh we had a question
that came in the last hour for chris so
i haven't even heard it okay let's fire
this plane
hey theo hey chris this is landon from
kansas city missouri and uh i was
calling in about a question for chris
but uh
first i just wanted to start by saying
that i seen theo on your little show
there chris and you're making fun of the
rat king's hair
you better leave it alone
you would better leave him alone all
right that guy's lost and i just want to
say that you look dutch and you look
like an aerodynamic dutch person at that
you sure did yeah
on another note i just wanted to know
how old were you when you got into
comedy and uh what what attracted you to
comedy thank you
first of all
that kid that's one of your favorites
he's a [ __ ] menace yeah that needs to
be [ __ ] boy right there dude what do
you mean it's probably your son dude
you've been talking about [ __ ]
somebody needs to [ __ ] start pumping
ritalin through that dude's air
conditioner events he needs to calm the
[ __ ] down the kid looks just like him no
that kid look at his nose man he's got
he's got lumped the [ __ ] up bro it's
what happens when you're you know when
you don't know who your dad is dude beat
you up a lot i like this kid though um
he's a good kid
i like that this is my kind of kid i
just also want to send a quick shout out
r.i.p to the neighborhood crackhead that
i grew up with which is also see i would
where i grew up in ridgewood bushwick it
used to be a place where you could get
stabbed but unfortunately now it's all
like vegan cupcake stuff but there still
was the neighborhood crackhead homeless
guy who was i mean we thought he was
going to die in 1997. he just died
recently scotty karate just passed away
and he was the neighborhood guy he used
to he would sing a billy joel song and
then he would do whatever thing anything
you wanted him to do he would do for a
dollar remember one time he backflipped
into this shards of glass knocked
himself unconscious and then we just put
a dollar on his chest or he would do you
know roofing work he would fix anything
you give him a dollar and call him
scotty karate and he would have no shirt
on and sweatpants uh almost 12 months a
year damn so and he survived for a long
time just want to say shout out scotty
karate yeah rip scotty and also yeah
they had a guy bus and he was mentally
challenged or something happened to him
and he was um he used to ride a bike a
woman's bike that had like a little baby
seat in the back
and the baby seat was always empty you
know and he said he had a little husband
that used to and people were always like
damn where's your little husband at and
so he would always just tell us he had a
little bit of a he had like a little
husband that used to he was looking for
him or something and yeah i don't know
what happened to that guy but just start
looking for kids that look like you and
[ __ ] where do they mail the sperm to
what give me a little more on the sperm
before you go off on this guy's question
not even any good you know i just
whatever you know i splooshed into the
tube and what is it like in there they
got a tube do you have different tubes
you have two options man you could
either get um your prostate pushed on
like a nurse will come in and profess
you do it and you just splooge it out
it's just like you're lying i swear to
god like it it's like a technique that
these these nurses are just good at just
get the splooge out if you don't want to
masturbate if i've ever heard a dude
somebody pushing and what you got a ass
and then the other one is they got um
you go into this room and they got um
they got uh
uh like nudie mags and all that and then
they give you the wi-fi my place had the
wi-fi and you could uh you know um jerk
off on the phone
is it like a house or is it a doctor's
it was a doctor's office so it's like
just like you know
you know secure coming in a place like
that i would come at somebody's house if
it were like a d you know like yeah if
you have your own room or something i'm
not gonna just in a doc or something and
what you just let them walk out of the
room yeah i just can't like it's if
you're peeing in a cup man i just came
up with my glue
yeah that's so bizarre though doesn't
that feel crazy
well the reason why it all started is
because
when i got uh my kid's mom got pregnant
you know she had taken like a plan b
after it and i got another girl pregnant
like four years before that so it was
like this and she was on birth control
so it was like some weird [ __ ] and the
doctor the ob gyn was like you know you
should get your sperm checked like that
that's that's abnormal so i went got my
sperm checked and and i donated it and
so they had it and then when i donated
it they called me into the office like
three days later and then we said good
bad they had a good bath well they said
to me like there was three doctors that
came in and they said listen they opened
up they said where were you born and i
said queen saint john's hospital queens
new york they said are you sure i said
100 percent and they're like well like
you verify it can you verify it with
your mom or dad and i said yeah why they
thought you were somebody else well i
called my mom and i was like where was i
born she said st john's hospital queen's
new york and i said are you sure you're
not lying to me like i wasn't adopted
she's like no you i swear to god you
weren't adopted so i said what's going
on start to get nervous and he said well
i have three times the amount of sperm
in every
load i mean he was you know he was i
forgot what technically whatever creep
who is a guy no he say his name he's a
guy he was a tie it was a chris hanson
yeah
and so so so he told me i have three
times the amount of sperm he said so he
asked me if i was born in um how do they
know about how much it weighs like can
they just well this microscope but they
act they said the only time they've ever
seen that like abnormality and mutation
of the sperm is as a child who's been
born near a nuclear reactor no they
thought maybe i was born in russia near
chernobyl i'll tell you this dude if i'm
gay bro i would be shocked
see if i'm gay i'd be
if i'm gay i'd be relieved yeah that's
the thing with me is because i can't
even really take a good look
because my father's still alive so my i
got an old school father
75 year old brooklyn you know tony balls
is his nickname so i can't even look
inside to see if there's a little gay in
there because it feels like there's a
little game there like like i'm
plant-based i'm on a plant-based diet
right now and you're building like a
strong gay you're built like a strong
and i'm a strong gay and people tell me
you know i'm a power i'm a i'm a power
bottom
um i got a big fat ass um i love whitney
houston my favorite movies little women
or pretty woman um you know i [ __ ]
jerk off to guys like all those things
i think it's okay if people know your
fears yeah because that's something they
can really relate to right but some
behaviors
yeah make people really sketchy yeah man
like you know and and like i met a girl
one time sorry i'd interrupt you but she
had i don't want to forget this and i
will forget
she had you know and we dated for a
while and she would wear the same
panties right and sometimes she would
wear them backwards wow and one time
they had like a little kind of duty kind
of touch interesting front does she have
fumes
i i don't know what that is but like you
know did the did the vag smell and oh i
don't know if i don't remember because
that's a big thing if a girl is fumes or
not oh i don't know yeah she this girl
just had switched her underwear around
you know yeah
but that may give off some fumes yeah
well
when i see them switch i'm out right now
you were just out of media like yeah you
know some guy who's letting go you're
[ __ ] up dude first of all that is
straight up how they make pink eye okay
that is where it's made my pink guy the
other day was [ __ ] wild and i had a
big stye in my eye yeah it was from
farting on my phone
oh my god that [ __ ] was wet right yo my
fans call me chrissy well farts do they
really because my [ __ ] sound like
they're in a well underwater ass crack
yeah
i got a deep deep deep [ __ ] man
that's what it is really yeah yeah i
have to get a colonoscopy oh wow yeah
the doctor because he i was telling him
like i played some audio on my farts and
i sent him pick some pictures of my
shits in the office and he was like we
need to take a look and when they went
in there he said take a look he said it
was all good gary nassar was it that
[ __ ] gymnastics a lot of the moms and
dads of the children i was treating
were young people that were watching guy
code and girl code and the principal of
the school i was working i was like look
we found out you're doing comedy and
doing these tv shows and they're like
it's not you can't be treating
handicapped children and also doing a
show about the guy code to hiding your
boner so you're going to have to choose
and so it was really this little kid my
little man aaron great kid he was in a
wheelchair had cerebral palsy so
cognitively he was fine no problems with
speech or his mind worked like our minds
but his legs didn't work from cerebral
palsy so he was sitting in his
wheelchair one day we were throwing the
ball at him you know he would throw it
at me i would you know rifle it off his
legs he couldn't feel it anyway so i
would just rifle it up you know light
him with you know burn him with
cigarettes whatever it
you is he couldn't feel [ __ ] i would
tell him to close his eyes i would just
yeah whatever
no
light his pants on fire joke around
have a pet bat bite him yeah if i want
to have children i can get girls
pregnant
instantly you know it's going to happen
wow because it's so a very high chance
so you're kind of yeah you should do
tour india or something yeah dude like
you can freaking definitely stop banging
out right or just i mean for a hunter
you might as well go door to door and at
least know what's going on and get some
of the joy out of it yeah instead of
throwing a whole batch does something do
for a hundred and twenty-five dollars i
just can't if you don't think about that
yeah and it got taxed
like in new york that's like dude you're
looking at 35 you're getting at 90 bucks
yeah bro i didn't get [ __ ] and did you
drive over there i drove um no i took
the train yeah
yeah it was in midtown man
where was this all she was who the [ __ ]
takes a train to [ __ ] jerk off for 90
bucks yo man louis ck yeah that's true
that's true yeah
he does it on the train yeah what if
what if his clothes are louis ck's
closer when he does another special yeah
he's just like hey i uh just want to let
everybody know in here that i'm about to
jerk off right and you can stay if you
want right yeah and then the lights just
go off and he's just on the stage love
it
i would love it man that'd be dope
that'd be tackling the [ __ ] head-on and
it's called you can stay if you want you
could say if you want that's what the
special is called yeah would you watch
it i would 100 watch it why not you
watch it i like lucy kay's comedy yeah
dude he's one of the greatest of all
time would you watch it in a uh one of
those interactive theaters like 4d 100
with those oculus virtual reality [ __ ]
and just get [ __ ] splooshed on 100
no that's not part of it
it's just you would like be able to hear
it better you're my fault man i'm hungry
i'm looking to nibble on some [ __ ] my
feet are disgusting they grow over each
other i could easily see that it's
disgusting yeah you almost you look like
somebody who would have webbed feet
almost i don't have web feet but i
believe i was born with broken feet and
they never fixed it yes i just my feet
are broken take care of yourself dude
okay that's what i'm saying you look
like a guy that definitely was in the
band in the school band even though he
wasn't really in it yeah
you look like you're on like the
marching thing with the flag yeah yeah
dude you look like my my third grade gym
teacher mrs klein
yeah she was like this lesbian we used
to call a liu kang you kind of look like
luke from street fighter if he was a
white dude that had money
thanks man yeah
yeah
yeah the blue eyes the blue ezra get out
of jail free card yeah well i think
women feel like i could protect them
because i'm a bigger dude or whatever
but i feel like you know i noticed like
the pattern it's like the first month
women are really into me and then it
slowly starts to be like oh this guy
wasn't what i thought he was oh wow you
know so but it's all good do you really
notice that pattern i noticed that
pattern like girls are usually in
they're really in the first few weeks
and then they're really out you know
after that like because you know
you know biting my nails eating my
boogers you know like doing [ __ ] like
you know like you know being too open
with them like hey i slept in the bed
with my mom until i was 15. you know um
being having anxiety being scared of the
dark not being able to fix [ __ ] you know
having one titty like way bigger than
the other um you know [ __ ] like that you
know yeah farting you know like that's
the real me you know i'll bite my
toenails yeah don't be
don't be the real you dude for other
people yeah you know say the real you
for you yeah yeah the good the good
thing about my hands
all right
i haven't held a guy's hands like this
hold
on with
bro huh you got those [ __ ] perfect
ass fingers they're not perfect dude
very very
like kind of the hands of the you could
barely [ __ ] choke somebody to have
somebody else just come and help you
people who get extremely famous it
becomes like that's a mental health
issue yeah like being a big celebrity is
a mental health issue that people like
it's almost like quarterbacks you know
got to take the those tests you know nfl
you know nba rookie camps they have to
go mandatory two-week training mandatory
about how their life's going to change
that should be with celebrities you
become an a-lister yeah deadline says
you're an a-list or a variety whatever
you got to take a [ __ ] taste of
[ __ ] you got to take a course bro the
wonder lick the wonderlic sorry i was
about to say the wonderlust because i'm
a [ __ ] dumb piece of [ __ ] no you're
an okay guy i appreciate it brother uh
well let me watch this because it's
gonna look like what do you think or it
still look fat well the jacket
definitely looks like uh something that
a trans worker wears yeah or somebody
that operates transit you know i'll try
okay yeah bus driver there's like a
transgender jacket oh no it's definitely
like a sexy bus driver [ __ ] yeah
something like that something that a bus
driver got your wife or or husband
that's yeah buy rate that's by
you know yeah crotch 100
yeah yeah man i [ __ ] it's fake
leather too yeah yeah you got that rare
body type i got it i'm built like a
conestoga wagon yeah
yeah i got so i got that rare i'm a
letdown for women man
yeah cause when i take my shirt off it's
a mess but you go to the gym all the
time i do but i just you know what i
mean i just got flubber so there's
nothing i could do you know i told you i
told you the guy told me i had leading
man faith best friend body really you
know some casting director said you got
leading man face best friend body that's
[ __ ] up thing to say but it was
hilarious yeah i tweeted it you know
yeah you got those blue eyes though dude
you look like a handsome guy who kind of
got uh yeah like when he was like some
elevator doors kind of smashed smashed
on him yeah yeah
yeah i want to start facetiming you more
too when you pee is it clear or is it
darker okay
i'll tell you this bro i bet it's a lot
clearer than some of the patches you've
had right yeah dude that is for sure
yeah man but uh but i've been but i'm
just waiting for these last std results
and then i'm gonna be celibate man i'm
gonna try to take two months off no
[ __ ] i'm not saying i'm gonna [ __ ] guys
but definitely no girls yeah
yeah but if you're only banging guys
because you're taking a break from women
that's not gay bro you have to actually
be a gay man man i know i feel like guys
can't go back you can't be a bisexual
guy i could be bisexual girl but guys i
feel like once you hook up with a guy
you're gay and he even texts me today i
didn't text him back but
the sh when he um yeah you don't text
people back you make people feel bad man
i i two texts out to you can't wait to
see you play boy i'm in la miss you love
you and you just wrote back i'll be at
the studio in 15 minutes yeah you know
what i mean i was running late for em
but that was that was i'm gonna text him
three days ago yes
that's really really good man yeah dude
enough of attraction between us i don't
want you getting any wrong ideas you
know it takes a lot of work to do that
so
i'm i'm always noticing about you and i
think it's dope thanks man but i will
say that you're a [ __ ] no i'm kidding
i'm good dude if i'm a [ __ ] bro hey
no offense if anybody is a [ __ ] or
and and still refers to themselves as
that that that that that that that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that that that that's not say that word
i apologize i didn't say that i i said
it so if you want to edit it out yeah
and just put quotes on their mind and
just refer to him yeah
it's so good i don't even know where i
am dude you want to piss in my hood
i want to go
do it all right bro i'm gonna [ __ ]
kiss you on the lips right now what
get it on camera what do we do can i do
it no come on man stop being anti-gay
just go let's go get him dude if i'm gay
i will tell you bro i'm not just being
gay for no reason man yeah thank god
these are these are uh these are men
wow it's too much wow it's too much guys
be good
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way
[Music]